at least one US Marine has died in Japan
after an American refueling plane and
fighter jet collided in midair searchers
are now looking for five others who were
missing David Martin is tracking the
search from the Pentagon David good
morning the accident occurred during
nighttime training off the southern
coast of Japan the training included
aerial refueling in which the f-18 comes
up behind the kc-130 the two planes hook
up and the f-18 takes on gas it is an
inherently risky maneuver particularly
at night we don't know what went wrong
but both planes went in the water there
were five crewmen aboard the kc-130 and
two in the f-18 two Marines were picked
up out of the water still alive but one
of them has now died of his injuries the
f-18 is equipped with rocket-propelled
ejection seats which allow the crew to
get out quickly but it's a very violent
event and and pilots are frequently
injured coming out of the plane right
now the toll from this accident is one
marine dead and five still missing David
thank you very tough morning for those
families thank you very much